what is patreon patreon is a cross
between subscriptions and Kickstarter
unlike Kickstarter patreon doesn't focus
on a one-time project it's aimed at
fundraising for long-term projects that
include recurring creations like songs
from a musician or episodes of a podcast
in our case your patreon pledge supports
the videos we create each month as we
attempt to build our patreon we have a
few questions for you what rewards or
incentives from film courage would you
be interested in why do you watch film
courage videos what kind of content
would you like to see film courage do
more of what film courage video or
videos has had the most impact on you
would you one day like to be in a film
courage video are there any other kinds
of videos you would like to see film
courage make please answer one or more
of these questions in this video's
comment section if you have additional
thoughts please share them we'd like to
use your feedback to make film courage
better and to help us build this patreon
page thank you thank you